called feminism guys honest citizens
honest citizen polygamy meant men in
power took women away from average Men
by force and other men were forced to be
a
unit
oh wow okay yeah polygamy was not a not
a choice women were forced due to
finance women were seen as property
Chris McCarthy thank you for the Super
Chat Lawrence Bullock do they have
common law marriage in the UK I don't
actually know I don't know what's common
law marriage when you live with someone
that's what I thought okay yeah do you
have that here I think we do things have
slightly changed I heard recently but
yeah there used to be a Thing If you
cohabit for a certain amount of time she
is entitled to uh you know like your
wife the household Essence yeah it's
still difficult yeah it's still it's
still it's still harder hard to get even
more about marriage yeah that's crazy
Daniel
um no no I'm saying
they're like they're like twisting men's
arms you will be married
you will
Daniel marriage has always favored women
um Mar I can't read your name when is
the Pearly waifu pillow gonna drop what
does that mean what's a waifu pillow I
don't know what that is oh I think it's
those um because in Japan they have
these long pillows where men can you
know single people can just hug them as
they send their pictures on it
come on major merch
okay can women lay off their hormone
hormonals or emotions change all the
time so that doesn't make us accountable
it's a terrible excuse your hormones
change you're not on meth
um do bees 87 a man was shot and killed
by police after his son called the cops
after seeing that his mother stabbed his
father the father who had a disability
had reportedly called the police over
the abuse prior Lawrence Bullock women
that proudly say they will not settle as
a big red flag because the fairy tale
man they're always looking for doesn't
exist and they're never satisfied
Michael federa 100 Super Chat yeah let's
go
um this is a cute conversation but the
time has passed for U.S and Western
women we are going overseas and sisters
it may take three generations to get it
back we wealthy fit older men don't want
you and we have foreign women now well
lucky for you I am overseas
okay Matt butcher um bottom line is if
you marry and have kids or and or have
kids with a lady it's a gamble you never
know what you'll get despite the red
flat despite red flags the odds are
against you
um okay
let me just refresh it real quick guys
like the video come on like a like is
free how many people we got in here two
thousand
oh we got a thousand likes you guys do
come through last time so I just exposed
myself depending who watches this video
so like the video please
that is what people are watching
um okay why do you think that
men or why do you think that men are
expected to deal with women's hormones
but women like us being hormonal every
month but women aren't expected to deal
with men's hormones that they're horny
oh
he said that women don't deal with men's
hormone um horny womens yeah you'll be
dealing with that yeah yeah you'd still
be dealing with it do you feel like and
do you feel like it's the same guys no
no not for the most part
um men men have to endure I'm washing my
hair I have a headache and and all of
that whilst if if you know and the guy
can't really say look it's that time of
the night for me I need to have this
whilst if a woman just
basically goes crazy and
loses her Collective [ __ ] every month
men have to kind of grind their teeth
because they can't even nowadays they
can't even say are you on your period
that is going to trigger more [ __ ]
coming your way just by saying is it
that time of the month love I just need
to know
thanks you have to download the app
yourself
together
[Laughter]
I don't know I think women go through a
lot of biological you know
imbalances throughout the month and
yeah that is what it is I feel like if a
man wanted it morning night morning
afternoon and night a woman wouldn't
give it back but a man would be happy to
just yeah because she's in her mood and
her you know I mean he'll run Tesco get
her whatever she wants and do whatever
but if you say to the woman yo I'm
feeling a bit come get on your knees and
it's a bit nah I got other things I want
to do and
I think because men you it's in you okay
I don't know I think men
is easier for men to be horny
it's because but it's because of our
home yeah
it's our hormones or hormones the best
question is about hormones like women
men are willing to accept women's
hormones and the way they are at the end
of the month but when it comes to a
man's hormones a woman's a bit like
even on the couch what I said would you
accept a guy cheated like they're just
they're horny it's just from time to
time you might [ __ ] a hoe yeah
okay so the primary hormone right for
sexual arousal is testosterone right do
you know how much testosterone the woman
produces you can check this as well no
it's I think it's like anywhere between
50 to 100 nanograms do you know how much
men produce
it's up to a thousand yeah exactly
that's what I'm saying so you know how
horny you get
times that by 20. that's what I'm saying
men
amazing exactly but dealing but you
dealing with his hormones would be like
well when he's horny can he have sex
with you or anyone else
okay okay do you see what I'm saying
okay
but because when when a woman has a
period meant to have the luxury of
saying I'm just gonna go out for a few
days I'm just gonna I'm gonna F that for
like two three days
even if you suggest such a thing like
look I just I just want to go and get
something from Tesco's what you leaving
because
[Laughter]
like I mean I think women well I don't
know from my experience I'm more horny
when I'm on my yeah you know when I'm
coming up too men genuinely don't want
to access women on their periods
the way it is unless unless your name is
Dracula and most people don't want to
know this
you're very quiet yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you agreed